volvemos con un nuevo repaso de la
información económica para ello contamos
una vez más con nuestro compañero jorge
hurtado jorge bienvenido otra vez al
plató de france 24 y empezamos con eeuu
porque ha anunciado que va a liberar
barriles de petróleo de sus reservas así
es ese país va a liberar un millón de
barriles diarios durante seis meses esto
para contrarrestar los precios altos que
sufren la energía y los combustibles en
ese país la gasolina está en una media
de 423 dólares el galón frente a los 287
dólares que costaba hace un año aunque
el presidente no dijo cuánto bajarían
los combustibles sugirió que podría ser
entre 10 centavos y 35 centavos por
galón los mercados reaccionaron
rápidamente y los precios del crudo
cayeron un 6 por ciento en las
operaciones escuchemos que dijo el
presidente yo by the fox
phillips coordinado esta liberación con
aliados y socios de todo el mundo ya
tenemos compromisos de otros países para
liberar decenas de millones de barriles
adicionales en el mercado nuestros
esfuerzos combinados suministrarán más
de un millón de barriles al día las
naciones se unen para negar a putin la
capacidad de utilizar sus recursos
energéticos como un arma contra familias
estadounidenses y las democracias de
todo el mundo
rodrigo y es que pese a que este intento
busca aliviar los precios hay que
recordar que el presidente bai ling ha
ordenado en dos ocasiones la liberación
de las reservas sin provocar un cambio
significativo en los mercados del
petróleo pero jorge cuéntanos qué sigue
que son exactamente estas reservas de
petróleo que tiene eeuu así es ese país
las creó en los años 70 esto tras el
embargo petrolero árabe las reservas
estratégicas es un conjunto de cavernas
de sal subterráneas en texas y luisiana
que pueden almacenar más de 700 millones
de barriles de petróleo en 1991 george
w.bush autoriza el retiro de casi 34
millones de barriles durante la guerra
del golfo en 2011 barack obama liberó 30
millones de barriles para compensar la
interrupción del suministro de libia la
idea de liberar petróleo tiene que ver
con la oferta y la demanda país en
espera que los precios bajen a liberar
más petróleo en el mercado los precios
han subido alrededor de un 40% solamente
este año y si ha sido más volátil en el
último mes como consecuencia de la
guerra en ucrania pero esto opinan los
expertos a propósito de la liberación de
la reserva de petróleo
hay que tener en cuenta que el consumo
mundial de petróleo es algo así como 97
millones de barriles diarios casi 100
millones de barriles diarios estamos
hablando de liberar un millón de
barriles durante un periodo de seis
meses más o menos así que simbólicamente
es una buena idea ha tenido algún
impacto en el precio de los futuros hoy
y eso es bueno o malo dependiendo del
lado del mercado en el que se especule
pero en términos de la gran función de
oferta y demanda no no es terriblemente
importante simbólicos y sustancial mucho
menos
bueno jorge nos vamos ahora está europa
porque allí en la eurocámara varios
economistas han comparecido porque
opinan que se puede no depender del gas
ruso aunque esto signifique inclusive
una subida aún mayor de los precios y de
la inflación durante un debate algunos
eurodiputados sostuvieron que la
situación actual no es comparable por
ejemplo a la incertidumbre que generó la
pandemia de kobe 19 en 2020 el diputado
español luis garicano criticó que
alemania alertará de que prescindir del
gas ruso provocará un desempleo masivo
en ese país uno de los invitados el
economista alemán georg shachtman dijo
que eliminar la dependencia es un reto
considerable tomando en cuenta que el 40
por ciento del gas que llega al mismo
europea proviene de rusia pero que un
primer paso sería rebajar a menos del 20
por ciento el porcentaje de gas que
europa compra a moscú interesante nos
vamos hasta argentina que sigue
defendiendo su acuerdo con el fondo
monetario internacional según gabriela
cerrutti que es la portavoz de la
presidencia del gobierno de argentina el
nuevo acuerdo para refinanciar la deuda
de 45 mil millones de dólares con el
prestamista era imprescindible
escuchemos
era imprescindible tener un acuerdo con
el fondo monetario internacional porque
yo les puedo asegurar que si hubiéramos
entrado en default los índices de
pobreza se hubieran disparado hacia una
crisis social en la argentina
inimaginable mucho peor que la que
hubiéramos visto en los últimos años
entonces el acuerdo con el fondo
monetario internacional lo que nos
permite es un escenario de estabilidad
un extraño de estabilidad con respecto
al resto del financiamiento
internacional en un escenario de
estabilidad por no haber caído en el
default que nos permita llevar adelante
las políticas que ya está implementando
el gobierno y profundizarlas para que
continúe el crecimiento para que
continúe el gasto social que necesitamos
difícil la situación del gobierno
argentino con este acuerdo vamos ahora
con los indicadores de las principales
bolsas mundiales bueno en las acciones
estadounidenses se desplomaron hoy
cerraron el primer trimestre con su
mayor caída trimestral en dos años esto
por la preocupación que genera la guerra
en ucrania en europa el dax 40 de
fráncfort cerró el primer trimestre del
año con pérdidas en torno al 10 por
ciento con respecto a finales de
diciembre motivadas por la pandemia el
19 y por la guerra también y en américa
latina' brasileño de acciones siguió el
escenario internacional y cerró a la
baja jorge muchas gracias como siempre
por este repaso de la economía mundial a
los espectadores les invitamos a que
sigan con nosotros en france 24 y a que
amplíen toda la información en nuestro
sitio web france24 puntocom
[Música]
[Aplausos]